hello ladies and gentlemen I'm Ryan
right here and Brianna white here
Brianna Wyatt has a gaming channel
called sibling rivalry so I was like
okay I should do I should the channel
[ __ ] me unbox all right don't let me see
what's in the box
and I forgot what the theme is so you
got to find the pamphlet at the bottom
so that I know they should put power
power power I am all about power I have
power over everyone I know I'm what you
call a master manipulator and I am
powerful in bed I'm telling you the way
these hips work is like launching a
missile that's no that's no lie first
thing I love if you look right down seen
it all my toy collection from all these
boxes and stuff oh my god my kitties are
gonna love this too you know be cool if
I like cut open the background to like
catnip in that day with all my it's kind
of too cute to have a cat rip apart I
know what is so cute is his mouth like
all the way off to the side and he
determined his mouth is over here this
trap is here
why is his smile to the right side of
his face so when he's determined his
lips move over here what what is that
classic determined determined he's like
ready to fight a battle
you look like Clint Eastwood trying to
take a [ __ ] that is not that's what he
looks like - I don't know it's cool
Captain America ever since Winter
Soldier he's so [ __ ] awesome Wonder
Woman what's in the blender woman ball
good thing I didn't cut my nails today
get a look inside Wonder Woman it's what
I said to Veronica the first time her
head and when because he could turn her
whole body invisible when not her head
and then her body where she can turn her
head invisible and freak people out yeah
that's really cool it's a two-part toy
honestly guys look at that it goes
perfectly together
what do you mean clamp I don't know what
I'm doing here right here oh there's the
notch okay got it got it I don't think
that's gonna work ion look at that are
you sure it's not closing oh you did it
Breanna little body you know look at the
nice thing I'm gonna make these to [ __ ]
later except later we're right now right
now they can do a scissor maneuver to
make it work cause he's so tall you just
got a giant head I know then he goes
down on her he can you it's like he just
can't do it
yes I'm like genuinely really excited
for this I bet every time I go to the
99-cent store I look for puzzles that I
can do that are like 50 piece puzzles
this is double the challenge hundred
piece of kylo Ren from Star Wars Lee
the force awakens oh my god I am gonna
Instagram this when this is done follow
me on instagram so you can see it when
it's complete the pin with the flash 1up
box power I don't know if you guys can
see this well it's
come on you in the flash and you guys
see it it's so fast because it's the
push oh this is interesting
it's an air fresh that's sexy right
there air freshener of Harley Quinn and
I can actually sort of smell it I don't
imagine Harley Quinn would smell too
good though what she totally looks like
I know she's always physically active
she's probably sweaty and stuff I just
you really care to shave her ass someone
asked guy you know one thing I don't
like is when I draw her hairy ass hairy
asses are gross it's different when I'm
having sex with a human being they don't
want them to have a hairy ass different
standards common sense
Goku sticker love that hey guys there's
a video my Instagram that Malik Clay
black Phoenix studios did that
transforms me into a Super Saiyan you
should check it out I'm using this 1up
box to promote several things yes
alright and I think the shirt the PA
star resistance yes yeah cool
whoa that's so intense it's like
Superman Superman Saiyan that's awesome
wait wait thumbnail time pointed it
if we're gonna be like you guys didn't
make that real facial expression during
the video I thought you guys were gonna
have a reaction like that where we look
like that now I usually take off my
shirt but I've been losing some weight
and I don't want Briana to get too
turned on right now
that's right I could fit two shirts now
that's awesome boom with my new muscles
I feel that I worked out my arms yeah
you did yeah you proud of you anyway
there's a link of the description box if
you want to get a 1-up box they work
like axe commercials they get you chicks
ranked that right Briana yeah you know
anyone with a 1up box you just gravitate
towards Emily Munk young cheese trap and
so there's a link of the description box
if you want to get one be as cool as me
and I heard no profit if you guys buy
and Briana has a gaming channel that we
talked about earlier sibling rivalry
check it out Let's Plays and such would
you have her curse truly you just did a
video of battlefront
you guys should definitely check that
out yang Yang and follow us on our
social networks the Facebook's the
instagrams the twits
so do that because might get product
placement unlike today's video which is
not that at all this would be good
enough for them right I just submit this
video and we're done okay